hello there reject nation i'm greg
john came across an article that was
sent our way
that is very interesting in the
title to say the least um
don't know the details on this but
let's dive in we're gonna go through
this article periodically stop to talk
about it you've seen one of these videos
before you know how it goes why am i
explaining all this for you guys you're
smart you've seen a youtube video before
so the title of this disney resetting
star wars
erasing last jedi i thought
ryzen skywalker was already trying to do
that yeah i was gonna say
all right together with the force
awakens
a new rumor has hit the net offering
that some sort of disney star
wars reset is in the works that we'll
see force awakens last jedi and
skywalker
basically erased the rumor comes from
the future ruler
i already think this is a bad idea by
the way wherever it comes from the
future ruler of earth
the doom [ __ ] overlord dvd youtube
channel what a
great name i gotta subscribe with that
name alone has got me subscribed who
recently offered that a star wars civil
war is happening at lucasfilm
between kathleen kennedy and john
favreau that's cool
um doom wait this says doom [ __ ] up here
and then down here says do mock which is
it which one is it
i like doom doom [ __ ] better is that a
typewriter i feel like it's
doom [ __ ] and i feel like dumac is the
typo
but then scrolling down again it says
dumac here all right whatever
we'll find out never know it's a great
video so far dumock also previously
provided the skywalker spoilers
oh he was the one and prior to marvel
studios announcing a new director
writing team on the captain marvel
sequel blah blah blah
stuff about captain marvel who cares
disney star wars trilogy getting
nullified here we go getting back to the
rumor dumac says the
plans are in place to save the star wars
franchise which involves the abrams and
ryan johnson trilogy getting
nullified it's claimed the disney star
wars trilogy will be erased
using a concept that was recently made
canon in the star wars rebel animated
series oh well let's see how this go
maybe
maybe with if following some sort of
canon
established outside of the disney star
wars movies this could be a saving grace
for fans we'll see and the season 4
episode 13 installment titled
a world between worlds the concept of
the veil of the force was introduced a
mystical dimension of the force that
connects all time
and oh they're doing like alternate
timeline [ __ ]
that's what it sounds like we're going
yeah oh so they're not going to erase it
they're going to do
okay you can't erase it it's here it's
out
people own it we saw it i don't know
release the snyder cut him all right
goodness gracious release the the other
cut
release the cut where you didn't have
any cuddles and you just had a different
idea
release a new production team to do a
new shoot
today that's pretty much what i'm
getting out of i have received
confirmation from two additional sources
claiming this is
spot on that indeed lucasfilm realizes
they have a
massive problem on their hands that the
star wars franchise is all but dead
i don't think so i think it's that bad
oh come on
and despite kathleen kennedy's hatred of
this idea
of course she hates it she spearheaded
this whole thing lucasfilm is preparing
to render the sequel trilogy
nolan void oh this is great i hope this
i hope this happens this is
just so fun this would be so funny just
imagine the deluge of editorial youtube
videos
and the kathleen kennedy hadosphere i
love
i love adults in the business who don't
know how to handle
twitter it said that the events in the
force awakens last jedi
and skywalker will be removed from canon
isolated in their own alternate timeline
of course
and regarded as an else world like
installment
under the label of star wars legend man
whoever
this isn't how i wanted this to happen i
didn't want this to happen as a means of
fixing a mistake
who invented the alternate timeline el
who who like hundreds of years ago
whoever came up thousands maybe whoever
came up with it they deserve a lot of
money because oh yeah
this is the way we're of course
correcting everything so what
this is is explaining is that a star
wars multiverse will be created which
will isolate the disney uh star wars
trilogy
as being a part of a separate universe
we did this with star trek also can you
bring back
han solo can you remember harrison ford
and mark campbell again
yeah can we get some more cgi carrie
fisher in there
which i'm sure we can and i don't want
to
please do this this would be just so
entertaining oh
it doesn't nothing matters anymore i
want to watch them make it worse
everything is arbitrary
that's the star wars reset incoming doom
call continues by noting
the details can't be verified but says
there may be proof it's happening in the
rise of skywalker oh we're going to get
some
oh ways of all right i see where this
article's headed it's further noted that
the plans are not set in place as again
kennedy is set to hate the idea and is
set to be doing everything she can to
crush it as if the plan comes to pass
everything that kathleen kennedy do with
the sequel trills you will be destroyed
tossed out and declared
obsolete dimcock feels the plan will
happen
well he was right about a couple things
a massive reset is going to hit the star
wars universe he says
in this format though really is this the
way to do it uh
okay hold up all right let's let's pause
and we'll go through the rest of them
this sounds like i feel like it's such a
fun thing
i want it i want it because this sounds
like a terrible idea
i want it because i don't care and there
are no more rules and everything is
arbitrary because if you if you do this
then that just means that this is like
the
movie equivalent of every time i used to
like fail the first trick on a tony hawk
pro skater level you just restart the
game yeah
you don't really get anywhere you just
you know waste a lot of time
playing and diddling and so like i can
definitely
i've i would have loved this if this
wasn't the way we got introduced to it
as like a let's erase this sequel
trilogy f kathleen kennedy like that's
the thing it's like
this is not gonna happen dude i don't
think this is half this is not gonna
happen i think a massive overhaul is
coming just because of like the lack
of pleasing everybody with things like
this trilogy
solo etc between rogue one and the
mandalorian they've already got some
stuff that works and yeah like
will they do a massive overhaul in the
movies probably i just think that what
they need to do
is give the creative control to filoni
and favro
like just do that because they seem to
be the two who
really know what the fans want and also
how to keep
original great content going
that fits in tune with what star wars is
really all about i don't
like god you know like this did you know
how confusing
a this would just piss off everyone who
liked the trilogy b
this would just confuse the hell out of
people what the hell would you call this
don't announce episode 7-2
don't announce it just just in a few
years release star wars declare it's the
official
part four to the original trilogy and
there you go you've got yourself a
halloween
situation i mean yeah like if if you
want to do this
don't i mean don't do it i i mean do it
because it would be entertaining
it would be but i'm telling you but it
is it's one of the rarest
leave it be i'm going to cyber catholic
this isn't going to work just let it be
and do something else because no matter
what you do you're never going to erase
those films from
actual existence and we're all gonna
have to live on this timeline where they
came out
and people weren't all together pleased
i mean and also it's an
insult to everyone who worked on those
yes it is
the rise of skywalker albeit i thought
was a really fun movie
it's also a a [ __ ] all right it
is
it's i'm not kathleen kennedy's biggest
fan but like
i also think that she gets like such
hate
i mean it's insane to me i just find
this i
the fact that they're even possibly
considering this idea
i love it yeah i hate i hate love this
i really do okay but let's see maybe
maybe they'll sell us on this pitch of
course it's alternate timeline
my god yeah because this is what jj did
with star trek
[Laughter]
this is what he did to justify half the
[ __ ] they did with star trek
details how disney star wars will get
undone
i can't get over the story
because like this is the thing is we
like appear like i i love in one respect
how
much involvement there is of fans in the
discourse of how these films get made
but also it's
it's fascinatingly hilarious to watch
studio suits wriggle and go
i don't know let's just erase everything
let's start again there's a multiverse
everyone's got their own music
i really think with the way how sonic
went
like okay what happened with sonic was
one thing and then what happened what's
going on
are two totally different like those
aren't even similar
this is a spit in the face this is yeah
this is not and
this is this is embarrassing if they go
down this road it is it's it's
embarrassing
it is as like as like big adult business
people
you can't go people didn't like our
movies so we're gonna say it doesn't
count now
are you guys happy it's like trying to
fight racism by taking down old episodes
of tv it's like okay
thanks guys but you're not actually
doing anything hey the golden girls is
better now
yeah it is my bad actually
thanks for fixing it emperor palpatine
had a room on the second death star
called the room of mirrors
which was also when harry potter and the
half blood prince the mirrors were
created
by the emperor prior to death star
through the dark
side ancient sith rituals these mirrors
linked to the veil of the force served
many purposes
using them palpatine could manipulate
the force in many ways to further his
aims for example the use of the mirrors
allowed palpatine the cloud that
where is any of this in the movie the
cloud the jet is is this all in some
book
this is all a head canon based off
another piece of cannon from that rebels
episode just imagine a studio
like clearly there was so much cannon we
didn't understand what cannon can we
pull from well there's this thing in the
rise of skywalker book is it in the
movie no but it's in the book okay can
we use it you know what i do this
episode of rebels establish this thing
you know what i adore about this that's
brought this into such high relief
is that we don't demand this level of
accuracy or vigilance over [ __ ] based on
real history
people on this timeline experience and
yet we are breaking backs
and digging around for like ancient
texts to figure out
what counts as a star war or not like
ah just forget the ones you don't like
let's just make another movie
so funny i want them to redo this
forever
i want them to try and make the perfect
sequel trilogy
over and over and over again just keep
bringing pal petite back
and keep reaching back into the old
movies and going
here's the loophole we found that could
make this maybe work are you happy yet
do you love
us now for example
the use of the mirrors allowed palpatine
to cloud the jedi council the concealed
himself and his dark apprentices from
the jedi and from four senses
that follow their fault this makes sense
because we didn't know he used it on us
all right yes using the mirrors allowed
palpatine to access the awesome powers
of the veil of the force they were
indispensable tools that allowed him to
rise to the pinnacle of ultimate power
does this conceit that explains how
palpatine survived darth vader thrown
him down the shaft from the throne of
the death star wow
wow i hope in your new trilogy you
explained all this
make a new trilogy to explain how in the
last episode of the newest trilogy
there's a palpatine again with the new
trilogy that's a remake of this trilogy
tie in at all to this trilogy that just
came
nah the next trilogy needs to remake the
structure of the prequel trilogy while
also
fixing the sequel trilogy while also
paying the ultimate homage to the
original trilogy
this is genius so apparently
apparently doom [ __ ]
goes on to explain that the emperor
created a second set of mirrors in
mexico
where he plotted the rise of the empire
this was right before he wished for
those infinite wishes
uh we got to read the you know what they
should do for the next trilogy
they should hand every audience remember
a book film pages of the book and then
have someone read it
aloud there should be an option like on
dvds or if you want the audio commentary
from directors
of you could have the book being read to
you while you're watching it
you're gonna have a commentary that just
points out how this isn't faithful to
the canon
a mystical dimension and where all times
collide
palpatine enters the veil and never goes
back to exigal
consigned to its alternate timeline
forever
okay so apparently there's something set
up they can use
some weird star wars mumbo jumbo that
they can use
that will use as a scapegoat to to read
this
oh my god i can't remember i can't stop
saying it this is such a silly idea
the emperor started using the mirrors to
return he dies as he was intending to
return to the jedi and bob's your uncle
and all our problems are solved so since
the emperor so
okay ideally so since the emperor never
survives
that means the events from the force
awakens last try and skywalker never
come to pass in the george lucas
so he's actually dead in this idea
they're lit
they're literally gonna undo the thing
that they randomly threw in at the end
to make it all better no disney sequel
trilogy han doesn't walk stupidly into a
lightsaber
i love that i do i actually love that
idea more that sounds way better
of han just
[ __ ] you really don't
feel those until they're really good and
in there leia doesn't fly like mary
poppins luke has nothing to run away
from him consumes no green milk
and i'm wow these are real nitpicky
things to get mad
these are the things that star wars fans
have been pissed off at and i am
informed there will be no amazing wonder
as she was born after the emperor's
death
just give everyone the money just give
all your fans a thousand bucks
so doom [ __ ] is upset duncan
is in support of this apparently the way
it sounds retcon the sequel trilogy out
of our misery
a lot of people are in support oh god
well
hey i mean if you want this please
keep in mind as dumb as that idea as
this sounds
because here's the thing it's still
going to be fairly in the same hands
i don't think it'll make your life that
much better this sounds like a bad
business investment
yeah just give those people who are mad
money like it'll do the same it'll have
a
bigger effect than this because what
you're going to wind up doing is
spending a bunch more money trying
to please a bunch of people and you're
also going to open yourself back up to
like you said you're going to have
similar management to disney probably
plus the dice roll of who's going to be
making that next movie
or you or or here's an idea
you could just stop watching this
trilogy
yeah if you don't like it don't watch
seven eight or nine anymore
you know what happens you've seen it
once or maybe multiple times you hate it
enough to remember the details
let them try other things out as they
try to fix the problem
i just i adore this because it seems
like they're describing
a universe they want to live in by
trying to make a movie like and just
piling more problems on top of a pro
just let it be move on to something new
so for all those who
want this petition it please petition
sign that petition
leave your thoughts down below i don't
care if you hit the like or dislike
button get them both just
leave your thoughts yes all of them i
want your entire head cannon as the
house is gonna work
doom [ __ ] ends up with well my friends
this is your glimpse into the veil of
the force literally anything is possible
here is branching alternate realities
converge and diverge in that mystical
dimension well his glimpse in those
mirrors is an alternate version of rey
and lurky within the veil are alternate
versions of palpatine
alternate versions of luke why don't you
just do one movie
if anything you should just daze the
future past this
yeah like one movie to course correct
you don't need to do
i can meet you there the veil of the
force sounds cool the veil of the four
sounds cool you can explain the [ __ ]
mirror thing but to do a
trilogy to undo it all i'd be like
that's not the real canon
just do some one thing to undo it that's
all you got to do
is one one movie yeah and and hey people
like days of future past and that even
didn't do a full
job of correcting the course but it did
enough to get it back on track this idea
sounds
silly but i also really want it because
i i love watching disney mindlessly
spend money
because they can and it's more cost
effective to them
to try and make another challenge
guys you won't ever but this is the
thing if they do the veil the force then
we can get them in the marvel multiverse
and then there are no more boundaries
between anything
luke is an avenger now this is the
greatest luke is an avenger i
i haven't laughed as hard as a video in
so long and we weren't even
we were just reacting to text
[Laughter]
just reading the news this was a real
treat thanks hollywood
well do you want it leave your thoughts
down below subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification
bell and hey it's the end of the month i
wanted to shout out
some people who are pledged for our
deleted takes behind the scenes
worked here they also get a name call
out and those folks today
are abby smith ian sotelo
sj94 bella kim
rightsee daniela aka danny
samuel castle james smith
chrissy rogrey marcus
word werderman wordman andru baba
thanks guys for being pledged hopefully
you've been enjoying that reward tier we
have more people on that
than ever because we post 1.5 times as
much now there
soon be two times stay tuned
thank you guys thanks for your love
you